حقيبه قديمه باليه ومهترئه عمرها 40 عاما
زارت كييف واشنطن وتوكيو ورغم بساطتها فهي
دائما ما جذب عدسات الكاميرا والان بات
تشعل منافسه للظفر بها فما هو سر حقيبه
المستشار الالماني
يحرص على حمل الحقيبه الجلديه نفسها في كل
المناسبات الرسميه صحيفه تقول ان السياسيه
المخضرم يحتفظ فيها غالبا بنظراتنا
القراءه ومذكرات احاطه ما حصل مؤخرا هو ان
متحفا تاريخيا ومؤسسه فكريه في المانيا
يتنافسان للحصول على الحقيبه فور ان ينتهي
المستشار من استخدامها لكن ليس من المعروف
ما اذا كان يخطط للتوقف عن استخدام
الحقيبه قريبه تقارير تقول انه مرتبط بها
ويحبها لانها عمليه فيما يعتقد مساعد انها
ستبقى معه طالما انه مازال في عالم
السياسه